wer schon mal so einen pilz trip mit
magic mushrooms hatte weiß dass die
drogen ähnliche halluzinationen auslösen
wie lsd also es wirklich in sich haben
und außerdem nicht ganz ungefährlich
sind schon seit 60 jahren ist die
substanz die dafür verantwortlich ist
bekannt sie loszugehen
doch was hat es mit dem halluzinogen
stoff aus sich ein forschungsteam hat
jetzt das geheimnis um die zauber
politik gelöst wie genau sie also
funktionieren warum sie so gefährlich
sind und warum ihr wirkstoff auch als
medizin genutzt werden könnte in zukunft
jetzt den klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
schon vor etwa achtung 4000 jahren haben
die urvölker in mittelamerika wohl mit
halluzinogenen pilzen experimentiert ja
sogar verehrt und diese so genannten
zauber pilze zu spirituellen zwecken
genutzt denn die substanzen der magic
mushrooms haben tatsächlich
bewusstseinserweiternde effekte auf den
körper man kann sehr scharf sehen und
alles wird von extremen lichtern
überzogen es gibt studien zu diesem
magic mushrooms die hinweise darauf
geben dass die persönlichkeits
verändernde wirkung der drogen auch ein
jahr nach der einnahme noch messbar ist
und genau deswegen ist das image der
freizeit droge zu recht zweifelhaft und
der name sauber pilz der ist viel zu
positiv denn das regelmäßige einnahmen
der sogenannten zauberkiste kann
schlimme gesundheitliche konsequenzen
forschungsteams beschäftigen sich seit
etwa den fünfziger jahren mit den pilzen
denn ihr könnt es euch denken ihre
wirkung könnte auch in der medizin und
pharmakologie eingesetzt werden und von
großem nutzen sein natürlich nur unter
ärztlicher aufsicht den entscheidenden
wirkstoff der magic mushrooms isolierte
ein schweizer chemiker schon vor 60
jahren der name der substanz psilocybin
seitdem ist auch seine chemische
struktur klar genauso wie seine
wirkungsweise im körper diese ähnelt in
zügen der des glückshormons serotonin
nerven botenstoff der auf natürliche art
und weise in unserem gehirn produziert
wird und dort beispielsweise für gute
laune
ausgeglichenheit und erholsamen schlaf
sorgt damit bin ich zum beispiel ganz
gut gesegnet bei einnahme der magic
mushrooms wandelt der körper den
halluzinogen stopp
in seiner aktiven form um psycho ziehen
dieses bildet dann in unserem gehirn
tatsächlich an die andockstelle die
eigentlich für das glückshormon
serotonin gedacht ist absolut zu bieten
dann ähnliche halluzinationen wie lsd
aus auch wenn der rausch der pilze meist
etwas kürzer an studien aus den 60er
jahren beschreiben zwar bereits mögliche
ansätze wie dieses besondere moleküle in
den pilzen gebildet werden könnte doch
wie genau es entsteht war bislang
unbekannt gesucht also enzyme die die
pilze als werkzeug benutzen um die
biosynthese des psycho zu wiens zu
bewerkstelligen derjenige stoff der die
halluzinationen und
bewusstseinsveränderung hervorruft dies
ist jetzt endlich einem forschungsteam
aus jena gelungen er kennt es noch aus
dem chemieunterricht der synthese weg
solcher komplexer molekülstruktur ist
wahnsinnig kompliziert und erfolgt in
mehreren schritten den forscherinnen und
forschern gelang es tatsächlich diese
komplizierte synthese im labor
nachzustellen
dafür war es erst einmal notwendig die
entsprechenden werkzeuge der pilze also
die enzyme herzustellen dies konnten sie
tatsächlich mit hilfe genmanipulierter
bakterien und pilzkulturen umsetzen und
damit konnten sie die herstellung von
psilocybin im labor rekonstruieren ganz
ohne pilz zellen das ist ein
riesenfortschritt zudem haben sie damit
gezeigt dass die biosynthese in einer
anderen reihenfolge abläuft als bislang
vermutet
dieser erfolg ist tatsächlich nicht ganz
ohne denn es bringt die forschungsteams
einen schritt näher an ihr ziel das
hochwirksame hallo zu gene molekül im
labor bereit zu stellen um es dann auch
im pharmazeutischen bereich einsetzen so
können eben als medizin denn erste
klinische studien zeigen bereits dass
psycho zudem über gewisse heilkräfte
verfügt wenn es unter medizinischer
kontrolle eingesetzt wird es könnte
patienten mit lebensbedrohlichen
krankheiten wie krebs die angst nehmen
oder auch depressionen mindern wenn es
also medikamente wie psycho zu bienen
gibt dann erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier
bei klick zum wenn er kein video zum
thema und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier
also ein abo aufs auge und vergesslich
den
genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter
mit die zehn gefährlichsten drogen
bezogen auf ihre wirkung auf die gesamte
menschheit sehr aufschlussreiches video
also drauf klicken und mehr über drogen
wissen und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran